nowhere is this clearer than with hunter
by
if you or i did
one
ten thousand
of what hunter biden has done if we
committed one ten thousand the crimes
hunter biden has committed we would all
be in prison for a very we'd lose our
money we'd lose our house we'd lose our
reputation we'd be in prison for a long
time hunter biden gets to go into the
white house gets to do whatever he wants
and we know that more and more of this
each day
4chan now this according to jack pasobic
has reported this 4chan has cracked
hunter biden's iphone backup password
and is now leaking everything
i'm always skeptical of leaks
because you never know if the
information is accurate or not in this
case we have videos
of hunter pictures of hunter and
it makes his laptop look wholesome
actually i saw the link i click on it i
just wanted to see if there was anything
politically relevant there and then
immediately what you get is just
pictures and videos of naked hunter
biden i've probably seen that guy naked
more than i've seen any other human
being naked at this point including
myself in the mirror when i'm taking a
shower it's j so i had i just said okay
all right enough i don't don't need to
see any more of this
i get it it's a lot of crack it's a lot
of hookers it's a lot of
and it's a more importantly it's a lot
of financial crimes it's a lot of
corruption it's a lot of selling
american influence a lot of it
implicates joe biden
when it this is a little bit of an
unpopular take when it comes to hunter
biden
the more of his stuff that i saw
the sorrier i feel for him
i do i genuinely i told you i feel sorry
for some people when they're victims of
bad people
but i feel sorry for for most bad people
too i feel i feel sorry for criminals in
that they are not only hurting other
people they are hurting themselves
and this is an idea that goes all the
way back to ancient greece and old uncle
socrates
hunter biden is just
such a degenerate his life is terrible
he has completely destroyed his life
he's just
such a sad sorry sack of a degenerate
and i do have this thought
there but for the grace of god
go all of us
what do you mean hunter biden was raised
with all sorts of privileges right
that's kind of the problem
more of the messed up people that i know
are rich kids than poor kids poor kids i
i know messed up poor kids too but i
would say a higher percentage of them
messed up debauched decadent they got
drug problems they got all sorts of
problems people that i know grew up rich
not poor
that that can come with all sorts of
problems plus the guy had kind of a bad
life his mom died when he was really
really young his dad is just an empty
suit power hungry simpering politician
who
who
has pursued his backslapping career in
washington the whole time and his
they engaged in all sorts of corruption
and so i do i actually i i sort of feel
bad for the guy
i don't just want to make fun of all the
crack and the hookers and the
guns and the crime and when it comes to
hunter
all i care about when it comes to hunter
is what it means for joe
because i don't think it was just hunter
doing this stuff on his own joe biden
was very involved in this kind of stuff
and you see it more and more it's coming
out there's this weird story that
apparently
joe biden was in hunter's phone as pedo
peter
joe biden sometimes
famous people will use pseudonyms in
their personal communications in case
they get hacked and just just for
privacy and so they'll pick random names
you know mitt romney had this burner
twitter account called pierre delecto
and apparently joe bidens was peter
henderson or something like that and
that's what he would use in emails with
his family and so
hunter had him in his phone as pedo
peter
that's a little bit weird
you
you know that
joe biden was involved in hunter's
business dealings even though he said
that he wasn't we now know this because
we have a voicemail from the laptop and
cell phone from hell we have a voicemail
from joe biden
talking about hunter's business dealings
why is there a voicemail of the
president
talking to his son about his overseas
business dealings if the president has
said
he's never spoken to his son about his
overseas business
well first i'll say that uh
what the president said stands so
if he if that's what the president said
that that is what stands and second
secondly
secondly business dealings and he says i
think you're clear
how is that not him talking to his son
about his overseas business dealings
we're not from this podium i'm not going
to talk about alleged materials from the
laptop i will
i'm not
the voicemail i am not going to talk
about alleged materials on the laptop
it's not happening that it is not peter
i refer you to uh to his son's
representative
you didn't hear what you heard
that's the answer from the white house
joe biden had said i have never not once
not ever
spoken to my son about his business
dealings now we knew this was a lie we
knew this was a lie because hunter
admitted it was a lie in an interview
years ago hunter said yeah my dad when
he found out about all my corrupt
business dealings overseas he said you
better know what you're doing
and then he said oh oops i mean no we
didn't have a conversation never mind
so we already knew we heard it from the
horse's mouth
we already knew joe biden was lying but
now we know with 100 certainty because
we can hear it in joe biden's voice on
his son's cell phone because his
degenerate crackhead son
kept leaving all of his technology all
over the place for everyone to find and
he recorded every damn thing in his
entire life
so we now heard joe biden talking to his
son about his son's extremely corrupt
overseas business dealings which
according to the hunter laptop
involved kickbacks for joe biden
and carina jean-pierre the white house
press secretary says
whatever the president said
is true
no
if there is a disagreement between what
you heard with your own ears
and what the president said the
president is correct
twoplustwo does equal five
oceania has always been at war with east
asia corn pop always was a bad dude come
on man come on man
they're ju it's just pure gaslighting so
how do they get away with this it's it
requires a lot of hubris and it requires
a hubris
that that holds that
they are not accountable to anyone
you would think that they would feel
some accountability toward the voters
but they don't
they don't feel accountability toward
the voters or to anybody else because
joe biden he won the most votes than
ever in all of the history of democracy
he won 70 bazillion
votes
and so he's not worried at all even
though he's underwater now on all of his
approval ratings on every single issue
they're not going to change course
they're not going to answer anything
they are not accountable
to anyone and and
i don't i don't care for joe biden to
answer about his kids drug use i feel
bad i feel bad for that it's bad it's
bad to have a kid who's in trouble and
who's a degenerate and that's i i don't
think he should answer for that or even
for the hookers or even for but
joe biden certainly needs to answer
for his role in the corrupt business
dealings the multiple times that he's
met with hunter's business partners
while they were
well joe biden was in office and while
hunter was concluding this business or
in conducting this business he certainly
needs to answer that and what the white
house says is la la la la la you can
keep asking i don't care i don't owe you
any answer at all right now go to
externals.com and let me give you a back
massage i will not be using my hands
personally but i will be using xchair i
am introducing you to x chair and you
are so so very lucky many of us spend
more time every day in our office chair
than in our cars or our beds which is
why it is so important to invest in the
right chair to spend those hours with
the right level of support and comfort
to get the most productivity out of your
day x chair has made my time here at the
office so much better and more
productive it is the best my only
complaint about xchair is when my ex
share arrived these jackals at the
office my colleagues these hyenas all
tried to steal my x-chair okay
exterior's patented dynamic variable
lumbar dvl offers the ultimate
customized support also x-chair can give
you a massage can heat you up can cool
you down right now thanks to exterior's
new fs360 armrests you can even adjust
the armrests to the perfect position
absolutely fabulous fabulous
product right now there's a sale through
july 15th buy now to beat the price
increase go to externals dot com letter
x chair
kowles.com or call one eight four four
four x chair that is x share they've got
a 30 day guarantee of complete comfort
you can finance your purchase for as
little as 30 bucks a month externals.com
i'm glad you like that clip now hold up
i'm about to hit a million i'm very
close to a million youtube's probably
going to nuke my account at that point
that's fine whatever let's accelerate it
baby ring ding wamalama dingdong click
that bell subscribe get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you